okay in game already on the way against
some guy from the Netherlands I played
the Samish just a couple of games before
and got a completely winning position so
I tried again and I got the exactly same
line seems people are not really aware
what would kind of position there
they're getting into of course it's not
terribly better or anything but very
often they seem to play it without any
specific idea in mind
yeah of course I really like to prepare
you fallen in this position not sure
what what's the best setup 93 anyway
it's got a little bit of pressure
unknown on you three and deform maybe
it's also an idea to quickly switch the
Queen over this move also takes an eye
on the a5 square just in case it's got
the idea to play the Knight to c4 or be
three or something like this an edge for
doesn't look like a bad position for the
Queen
of course I have to watch out for 1976
saw a similar moves yeah maybe I can
flick this end to provoke b6 this car
also covers be three in case of the
night coming to a five okay now over 2h
for the plates 95 now I simply happy
fourth I think and this already looks
like you're dangerous attack so I think
he needs to do something against this
year for instance this move so now efore
is got night to g6
but what about playing in a position of
fashion here not for directed tech queen
bee three changes queens I take maybe I
could I could even think about taking
with a pawn in this position to also get
the H file open I still at the bishop
pair okay I think I need to take with
the night in order to keep an eye on
Bishop f5 idea what would be then to
play Bishop to d2 looks you want to just
play with the bishop pair it's not a
terrible position for black of course
it's just just a normal game that's
that's really surprising
one for the body form d e f ee Knight
takes e4 don't I have something
dangerous then I don't I don't see
anything concrete we should be five well
it doesn't look dangerous Bishop 2d to
simply
yeah I need to play a little bit quicker
of course yeah of course as I saw that
don't think it's it's it's really
dangerous for white
okay interesting I've an idea this one
if he takes on a 3 then e 4 and it
really opens up the position big time
then you form de fe
it's got done nagi for I have got tween
f4f seven assaults is always a huge
problem if it takes only for now but of
course if he retreats the night I fe5
which is also very dangerous not sure
what is what what could be a good
defense for black looks really dangerous
rook c8 maybe to take on c3 in case a
tag on f5 does he have some and some
other trick in this position
yeah it's got clock running down now now
e5 what what what about f7 yeah take f7
like I cannot take 85 conveniently but
it can't be bad to take on f7 of course
ok what about queen age 5 tie one [ __ ]
of age 6 is also an idea
wow what a position Bishop takes h7 is
also possible
okay what am I doing here I was so busy
staring at the great position that i
forgot to make a move now I'm completely
lost i guess one joke check check check
Oh what particulars or addictions
whatever done from this comes with its
position oh man got anything wins I
guess
now I can just take the five and and
everything oh my